LAURA:  AS OBVIOUS AS IT SOUNDS
THAT JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL JUST ON THE
MISSING TEXTS BETWEEN THE TWO
FBI AGENTS.
HE MERELY TOOK POSSESSION OF THE
PHONES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
THE FBI CLAIMS THEY COULD NOT
GENERAL JUST TWO DAYS AFTER
SENATORS DEMANDED THE ANSWERS.
GOOD FOR HIM.
FOX NEWS CAN NOW CONFIRM THAT
MUELLER BUT BACKED DOWN WHEN HE
WAS CONVINCED NOT TO AND WAS 1ST
REPORTED BY THE NEW YORK TIMES
EARLIER TONIGHT.
LET'S EXPLORE ABOUT WITH THE
FORMER HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR AND
>> AND HERE IN THE STUDIO MY
FRIEND AND ATTORNEY DEMOCRATIC
PROFESSOR, LET'S START WITH YOU
ON THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORT
THAT THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO ASK
>> EVERYONE SHOULD LISTEN TO
ELSE WITH VERY SOUND ADVICE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO FIRE
ANYBODY AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AND THE SUPREME COURT HAS
BESTOWED THAT BUT WOULD HAVE
BEEN VERY UNWISE, POLITICALLY,
AND WOULD HAVE SOUNDED LIKE AN
HIS CURRENT LAWYER'S ADVICE, AS
WELL, WHICH SAYS BE NICE TO
MUELLER AND SEE OF NOTHING TO
HIDE AND BE WILLING TO SIT DOWN
WHEN YOU DO IT UNDER ALL.
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS AND TRY
TO WRAP UP THE INQUIRY.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID YESTERDAY
WHEN HE LEFT FOR DAVOS, I AM
IDEA AND WOULD NOT HAVE FIRED
>> LAURA: A HUGE MISTAKE.
CONGRESSMAN.
SCOTT, THE IDEA OF FIRING
MUELLER, YOU CAN LOOK AT ME NOW.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PREROGATIVE TO DO
DOESN'T LIKE THEM, IS THIS A BIG
BOMBSHELL IN YOUR EYES?
>> IT IS A BIT BOMBSHELL BECAUSE
OF DONALD TRUMP AND FOLLOWING
HIS LAWYER'S ADVICE, GOOD FOR
THAT.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE, DONALD
>> LAURA: THING TO WORK FOR
HIM.
>> THEY REALLY DON'T AND
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF THE U.S.
>> LAURA: HE IS THE HEAD OF THE
TURNING THIS INTO A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS
>> LAURA: YOU ARE MAKING A
POINT OF POLITICS PRAGMATICALLY
AND APPEARANCE WHITE WHITE WOULD
LOOK TERRIBLE BUT AS POINTED
OUT, AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AS THE HEAD OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, HE HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO HIRE ANYONE AND
COULD FIRE MUELLER RIGHT NOW.
MY POINT IS DASCHLE CALLED ON
>> HE THINKS THE DOJ WORKS FOR
HIM.
>> LAURA: YOU EXPECT IN EVERY
PRESIDENT EXPECTS LOYALTY FROM
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK UNDER HIM
AND DON'T GO OFF HALF COCKED ON
AN ISSUE AND IF HE THINGS THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION IS
RIDICULOUS HE WILL EXPRESS HIS
FRUSTRATION.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
>> I HAVE A PROBLEM BUT IS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE FRAMERS MADE A TERRIBLE
MISTAKE BY COMBINING TWO
OFFICERS WITH THE ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT AND THE OTHER, THE
CHIEF PROSECUTOR WITH MOST
COUNTRIES DIVIDE THOSE IN LAURA:
OKAY, WE CANNOT READ DEVICE
THAT.
RON, WE COVERED THAT AND MOVE ON
TO THE MISSING TEXTS THAT WERE
DISCOVERED DISCOVERED AND A LOT
INCLUDING AN INTERESTING TEXT IN
FROM DOJ AND FBI WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION AND SAID ONE MORE
THING, SHE MIGHT BE OUR NEXT
PRESIDENT AND THE LAST THING YOU
NEED IS US GOING AND LOADED FOR
BEARS.
DO YOU THINK SHE WON'T REMEMBER
OR CARE THAT IT WAS MORE FBI
THEN FBI -- OR CASH OR DOJ.
>> I AGREE AND THEN REDIRECTED.
DOES IT INDICATE A TREATMENT TO
HILLARY OR MAKING TOO MUCH OF
THAT?
>> I THINK IT DOES BUT IS NOT
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE AND HAVE
THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION AND HOW
IT WAS CONDUCTED AND ALL THE
INFLECTION POINTS BENDING OVER
BACKWARDS NOT TO MAKE A CASE
AGAINST HILLARY WRITING THE MEMO
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THEY
INTERVIEWED HER AND CHANGING
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT WITCHES
CULPABILITY TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS AND IS ONE MORE
DATA POINT THAT THESE TWO FOLKS
IN THE FBI DID HAVE A POLITICAL
BIAS AND THINK THE FBI SAID IN
DOJ, WE CANNOT FIGHT THESE
THINGS AND JUST LIKE THE IRS,
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SENDING THAT
RESPONDS TO CONGRESS SAYING THEY
WERE DELETED
TODAY ABOUT WHAT REPUBLICAN
TACTICS ARE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE REPUBLICANS, MANY OF
T HEM, ARE ALL TOO DESPERATE TO
DISTRACT ATTENTION FROM THE
RUSSIA PROBE AND TRY TO PUT THE
NOW EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE NO BASIS
TO DO IT, IT DOES NOT STOP THEM
FROM MAKING THE MOST SCANDALOUS
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST THESE
PROFESSIONALS AT THE FBI
>> I AM NOT A REPUBLICAN.
LAURA:  CHRIS MATTHEWS SAID
SINCE WHEN DO REPUBLICANS HAVE
SUCH A PROBLEM WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
THEY COULD SAVE SINCE WHEN DO
THEY HAVE SUCH A PROBLEM WITH
CONSERVATIVES
>> I HAVE A MILITARY BACKGROUND
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND COULD
TELL YOU THE REASON WHY I
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE
SAME REASON I AM UPSET ABOUT
WHAT I HAVE SEEN BECAUSE IT IS
NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE NOT DOING THE
PEOPLE ARE NOT BEHAVING
P ROPERLY, YOU NEED OVERSIGHT
AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND TO ACT LIKE THEY
SHOULD GO ON WITH NO OVERSIGHT,
NO ACCOUNTABILITY
>> THAT IS NOT SOMETHING I WANT
TO SIGN UP FOR LAURA:  PROFESSOR
OF THEM WANT TO GO TO SCOTT.
>> HE RECUSED HIMSELF AND KNEW
BEFORE ANYONE ELSE DID ABOUT HIS
OWN BIASES AND SHOULD BE FIRED
NOW WITH NO PERSON IN THE FBI
FBI OR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL SHOULD NOT RECUSE
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY HAVE
WRITTEN THOSE KIND OF E-MAILS
AND TEXT MESSAGES AND THE
FAILURE TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM
THE INVESTIGATION TO ME IS A
FIREABLE OAF AT.
>> WHAT IS BOTHERSOME IS HOW
POLITICS AND THE GOP AND HOUSE
AND SENATE HAVE POLITICIZED THIS
INFORMATION THEY ARE RECEIVING
BY SUBPOENA AND THEN PICKING AND
CHOOSING PARTS OF THE AND USING
IT TO DISCREDIT DOJ AND FBI AND
ARE COMPLETED AND THE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS IN DOJ AND FBI ARE SO
NEGATIVE AND IS UNNECESSARY AND
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> WE WILL SEE IF IT WAS WEAPON
EYES TO STOP TRUMP BECOMING
PRESIDENT OR AFTER.